it's really interesting because i was
reading about the weather underground a
little bit
and you're familiar with who they're a
little bit like 70s terrorists
yeah they were like what was their what
was their their
driving force like anti-vietnam war i
think okay i'm not going to pretend to
know a whole lot about him
violent peaceniks yeah got it violent
pieces makes perfect sense
blowing stuff up yeah my understanding
is a lot of what they did was shock and
awe campaigns at like really early in
the morning i'm not going to pretend to
know a lot about it it's horrible
but what's interesting is that it
emerged out of the out of the
universities
and it was very there's a lot of
pro-communist sentiment among them
why out of the universities i don't know
but what i find fascinating about it is
that the us was engaging in these
conflicts to
stop communism and communism was
spreading
you know with these extremists trying to
end the vietnam war which would allow
communism to spread you know that's
really interesting
yes so much i have to learn about now i
had never really thought about weather
underground so i'm gonna need people to
send me links about the weather
underground and like maybe your parents
were involved or something because
yeah i think i think one of the guys who
was involved in it like obama had him
at an event or something that does sound
familiar yeah bill
uh what's his name bill ayers yeah yeah
i don't know a lot about it i'm not
gonna pretend to
but uh i do find it interesting that
we're now seeing this weird rise of
marxism and communism
when the cold war is over and it reminds
me of that simpsons joke which you
probably you probably don't know
because it's like super early 90s but it
like the joke was that it flashes to the
u.n
and then russia says something about
you know missiles or something and
they're like he says something like ussr
needs
something or other and they're like wait
a minute russia and then he starts
laughing and then he like hits a button
and then russia turns back to the ussr
like
they're back the cold war is back i
don't know it's been a long time since
since i've seen the joke i'm probably
butchering it but it was something like
that and so a lot of people have been
saying
a lot of what we see in the u.s that's
destabilizing us were the seeds planted
by enemies
you know during the cold war that were
supposed to take
root in 20 30 40 years they're here
that's really interesting because that's
something that andrew reipart used to
talk about
in his um book he wrote righteous
indignation and
he talked about the ways that they were
getting these ideas into colleges
which is why i was like what did you say
it came from colleges i thought it was
really
interesting well it was university i
only i only read a little bit
i didn't do a ton of research but i was
pulling it up because i was reading
articles
that were anti-trump and i was like hey
wait a minute wasn't that person in the
weather underground or something and i
looked it up and i was like oh it wasn't
right yeah i remember that lady we were
talking about earlier yeah and i'm like
oh i must be saying thinking of
something else
i don't know the ladies name princess
prittmer fox or something i think well
no no no i know her name but yeah who
was who's the lady who was like with
bill ayers
bill ayers girlfriend look it's like she
was with him at an event for obama or
something
and a lot of people took issue with it i
don't know i don't know it's no surprise
to me though
that it's it's it's gotten as bad as it
has
in terms of nonsensical like
nonsensical ideology right so you think
about what these people are spreading
and these weird marxist ideas and
they're not they're not really ideas
i would also i would kind of like are
you familiar with uh was it hypoxic
prion prion
prion prion diseases yeah so do you know
the
the basic function of prand disease yeah
from what i can tell it's basically so i
think wasn't mad cow a prion disease
i think so i know krootz felt jacob is
and these are diseases that you can get
from
eating other people okay so so so that
uh i
i avoid sounding dumb can you explain to
me how how a prion disease works do you
know
kind of so from what putting you on the
spot
not a fancy doctor so uh i don't know
exactly
my problem is that i'm starting at a
deficit because i'm not entirely sure
prions are
but i do know that it works against the
structure of the brain
so it's it's eating out holes in the
brain my general understanding
is that they're malformed proteins that
sounds right
and what happens is your body will
normally produce
i'm going to super simplify it let's say
it produces a protein that's shaped like
you know uh you know a certain shape
right
the the prion is shaped like a different
shape yeah these are misfolded proteins
yeah absolutely and so your body starts
producing proteins that are folded
improperly
and can't work and then your body starts
breaking down because all of a sudden
you've got a bunch of
like but you know you look let's say you
you need a bunch of proteins that are
shaped like the letter
r and then you get a bunch of proteins
like the letter f and your body's like
yo these don't fit what are you making
and they're like i don't know this is
gonna keep making it and then you die
yeah exactly well yeah the problem
is that the neurodegenerative so it
affects obviously first your brain which
means your whole
body falls apart it's actually really
awful that's what it feels like what's
happening with
this like intersectionality stuff so
there was recently
like a bunch of uh well it was like a
school curriculum release
yeah we talked about it a little bit the
other day every new school i downloaded
the whole thing
yep um i don't know what it is but it
was just like basic stuff
and and one of the things you see was
like we did mention this yesterday but
just for the context
where normal math problems are like if a
farmer has you know
3 600 oranges and his warehouse can
store 2 400
what percentage of oranges will spoil
right the question was
if there are 3 400 police stops and
out of you know 10 000 people 3 000 are
black what percentage
you know so it's basically creating this
weird intersectional
marxist meant idea trojan horseden
through regular math problems
yeah well now you're seeing too that the
two plus two equals five thing
yeah like that that to me feels like a
prion disease
well you want to talk about a misfolded
protein you try to inject the idea that
two plus two equals five into building a
rocket
you're going to have some problems
because and this is really interesting
to me the curriculum because
if you if you lay this out at the ground
level and then you go from there
everything else is everything else is
going on everything else falls apart
absolutely i think this is an accurate
analogy yeah so
now as a society in every level of
government
like in all over the place you have
these weird programs
that produce nothing like you know it's
interesting when
i when i heard you have all these
companies
promoting diversity and they're not
promoting
function and practicality so let's let
you take a look at gillette for instance
what does gillette do well gillette
razors they make razors yeah you remove
hair from your body
yeah okay and so they made a commercial
that was about men being toxic
yeah like what does this have to do with
selling razors you know i used to i also
always talk about this with my friends
i'm like can you please just give me
something where like the commercial is a
guy going hello
i make razors they're pretty good it has
three blades
it doesn't hurt your face and it takes
the hair off give it a shot
i think it's i think it's great thank
you can commercials be like that that's
how commercials kind of used to be
right yeah they you know remember the
commercial for head-on do you remember
that
yeah with the the stick that you put on
your forehead it's so weird it's really
really good the commercial worked
yeah because it just repeated itself
three times and then stopped
head-on applied directly to the forehead
head-on applied and that was it
yeah you know what the opposite of that
commercial was what have you seen the
quizno commercial with the weird animal
screaming
no it's considered like one of the best
advertising campaigns ever
because it's this really creepy thing of
like
animals screaming a really awful
discordant song
about sandwiches and they're like weird
animated things screaming yeah and
people just will never forget it you
know i think i had a horrible nightmare
about this once there you go but i would
never forget it
holy cow i guess you're right the
head-on thing is like a good ad so
anyway back to the point with the point
with joliet these are companies
that are prioritizing making an
advertisement about
men being toxic and not about a good
product yeah
surprise surprise the company is like
losing money yeah they're not doing so
great last i checked
to be fair though a lot of people played
this up like this big get go broke thing
when actually the company was doing
poorly already because of the
subscription services
yeah you get cheaper razors you know
like harry's or dollars yeah dollar
shave club perry's yeah
and and gillette was maybe we'll try and
call men
bigots maybe what made them think that
would work well their next commercial
was kind of
a reversal oh yeah the next commercial
they did was like
this ripped blonde hair blue-eyed white
guy with a white family
he was in the military with a family
like dude
like you got complaints about it man but
that's like entirely in the other
direction
anyway the point is you're not it why
would anyone support a company
whose focus is on improving diversity
instead of like i don't know making
socks
you know what i mean that's my first
criteria when i'm looking for socks
it's to know what they think about me as
a woman that's right
only thing i care about and my delicate
feminine feet
i mean i think this is part of the the
problem i mentioned earlier where media
can only go in one direction yeah
but this is what i mean when i talk
about the prion disease yeah it is a
cultural prion disease
where these these companies are
there's malformed proteins spreading
throughout the company you have a
company of 100 people
and from the top from the ceo all the
way down to the lowly workers they make
socks yeah they make great socks the
best they're the best socks everybody
agrees
okay and then one day you introduce
intersectionality
to one of on a mid-level mid-level
manager and now he like
forms differently he no longer interacts
properly with the other parts of the
company
he starts seeing all of these things
that are wrong because his worldview
just
malformed yeah everyone's he doesn't
respond to the bosses properly he
doesn't because they're racist
all his employees are doing everything
wrong because they're not as woke as he
is
i could see that at both levels so
here's what happens yeah
this person's upset but protected by law
my boss is a bigot you can't fire me
that's against the eeoc
regulation blah blah so then they say we
have to comply
with some of these you know training
programs which spreads
the prion disease now you've got half
the company
that cares less about making those fancy
socks that everybody loves
and is more concerned about making sure
everybody's holding hands and
you know diversity and inclusion all
that now the company is making crappy
socks
they're falling apart right so like the
prion disease
you your body can't function because
half the proteins aren't working with
the rest of your body
here's here's the worst part though the
brands don't work with each other either
so these these woke crazies in these
companies are
they're canceling each other yeah they
think all the time
so so then the company just plummets it
just collapses
scale that up to our to our to our
country and that's what's happening
yeah you've got you've got you know bill
de blasio
with painting black lives matter with no
permit
with taxpayer dollars with all the nypd
that was malformed proteins that don't
match that make no sense
that it's damaging supporting the riots
damaging the riots damaging
911 memorial part of the cohesive
structure
tradition memory memorial we no longer
fit with that
it's bright it's being ignored it gets
shut down the fact is
not that it was going to be stopped
or i should say it's it's not like
somebody decided we're gonna shut this
down
the problem is that there's magic money
to to manifest out of nowhere for black
lives matter
how do we ever get to a point where they
had to consider not having the lights
how come it couldn't have been the city
of new york guarantees that if you ever
don't have the funds or the manpower we
will guarantee it by any means necessary
right we as we as a society whether it
was in
you know whether it actually ends up
happening or not prioritized
a new fringe unhinged
ideology with no real goal
that can only sow discord over
remembering those who who died and whose
lives were sacrificed
in trying to save others it sounds to me
like
the 9 11 memorial was was built when we
all came together
to recognize you know what it means to
be an american
how we stand together and that was when
we were very very unified
yeah we built this memorial and we
pledged to never forget
now we have this expanding you know
malformed protein spreading throughout
our our you know culture and started it
existed you know during this era too oh
yeah
it was in the universities yes and now
these people have spread it
outside of universities do you remember
when we used to say
i don't know if you used to say this but
i certainly used to say this and maybe
just because of my kind of conservative
background
we used to say imagine what it's going
to be like when these kids get out into
the real world
and they realize how hard the real world
is and no one's going to give them the
time of day if they're just these soft
buttered butter soft little biscuits and
and and it turned out that they were the
real world and they're turning into the
real world i
i called this oh you did i i said it
over and over again i was like
these so a lot of people i'll i'll be
fair
i there were periods where i would say
something like these people are going to
try and get a job and they're going to
get a cold rude awakening right
that's kind of why you know outside
that's true it is true so separating the
micro from the macro
you get some of these kids to graduate
they go work for a company and the
company's like
what and they go oh but give it a few
more years
and more people keep joining the ranks
positions
the universities are essentially
cranking out
malformed proteins into our society
and once our body is inundated with
these the proteins themselves do not
produce
it is the equivalent of gillette arguing
about toxic masculinity instead of just
giving me
a face trimmer a beard trimmer or
something so imagine what happens when
you have the cdc
ten percent of its employees have
demanded they sign on to a letter
calling racism a public health crisis
yeah makes literally no sense so what
happens when our manpower for the cdc
is overrun by this nonsensical ideology
then you get a pandemic and they blame
trump for it dude this is something that
has really troubled me
ever since since my whole career has
been kind of at hospitals in nursing
homes working with old and sick people
and i started to pay attention to
culture and and i started to think what
happens
when this kind of nonsense starts to get
into
science what happens when we stop
looking for the truth and start looking
for what fits
our little malformed protein ideas yeah
like
what's gonna happen then is it is that
the end is that how the world ends
seriously like how are we supposed to
move
forward do you know the legend of john
teeter
no it was an old internet legend where
where this this man
claimed to be from the future he made a
bunch of predictions and it was a bunch
of funny internet images of light
bending and stuff
and it was nonsense but a lot of people
believed it was real
and the idea was that one of the ideas
he had and and
no none of these predictions came true i
mean maybe some some people still
believe this stuff
i thought it was a fun website i never
believed in it but uh one of the ideas
was that the us would break apart
that the east coast would be unite like
the east coast
would essentially be the remnants of the
federal government
and it would be aligned with uh europe
the midwest northern states would
be like basically basically become part
of canada
the southern uh southern you know
midwest and south would be part of
mexico
and the west coast would join china
really that was like one of the
conspiracy theories from back in the
late 90s early 2000s that's fantastic
that it was fantastic no that kind of
feels like what's happening
because all the federal government is
situated on the east coast right
and sure whatever we have more in common
with europe they're kind of they kind of
look down their noses at us
and then california seems to like them
some china
they love themselves from communism they
sure do yeah not the rural areas though
oh no yeah so i would only take really
serious issue with the southern part of
for texas for example joining forces
with mexico i don't really see that
happening right
texas is not that kind of state i'm just
saying like that idea i thought was
silly that is so interesting but the
idea of the us fracturing
yep i i i see it as possible i think
people
people have an optimism bias and they
don't want to believe
it's it's you know everything's
happening right now
john podesta's the war games they did i
don't think people realize the severity
of what it means when the boston globe
and the new york times report
that the establishment republicans old
before trump
and the democrats teamed up to play out
scenarios
and ultimately determined that it was
preferable to have the west coast secede
from the union than allowed trump to win
the presidency
this was not some like you know the mit
rolled some die and a computer program
said this might happen this was
literally
the politicians themselves making
decisions for themselves
yeah this wasn't like two weird people
sitting at a podcast table for example
on a friday night talking about you know
the state of the country
i mean there are politicians they were
literally playing like d and d
essentially that's pretty funny yeah
actually that would be a really fun
thing to do
like maybe like we should probably try
and set up some some i'll do air quotes
war games we should that'd be fun
it'd be that'd be a real fun thing to do
maybe like on the weekends yeah
yeah we could probably do this yeah so
based on what you know about these
politicians and stuff they've done in
the past what do you think they do oh
man
i would i would play joe biden yeah the
whole time i would be like
and no one would have any idea what i
was saying yeah it'd be great no i think
i'd get to be trump
yeah yeah what and i would just fight me
for it i would you want to play trump
yeah i want to be trump it would be fun
to you know
but here here look listen we could play
a war game scenario
and uh and i can be silly and be like ha
ha now i'm going to launch
a bunch of you know like attack
helicopters but these p these
politicians
were actual right yeah you have to
actually think about
what the person you're acting as would
be doing in the situation
i think it would be interesting and i've
heard this a lot
you know growing up that empires only
last you know 250 years or whatever i
have heard that as well
unsettling it seems like
you know i don't know there's there's
great risk ahead of us maybe that should
give you a kind of peace
because uh maybe it's just what's gonna
happen maybe it's what's meant to be and
maybe
we can salvage part of the country and
go on and or maybe trump wins in a
landslide because people are scared of
that idea
entirely possible as well you know
i wonder about what's happening with the
collapse of the economy
and i wonder if this will force
universal healthcare
what uh one i could be wrong about this
my understanding about universal health
care in europe
was because of world war ii yeah they
had yeah i have heard that as well
it may have been one or two but they had
no choice because everybody was
like literally wounded and dying just be
like we're going to try and take care of
everybody and figure out how to fund it
because
we have to do this well they did that in
spain just now they finished
whatever they were finished changing
over their health care system because of
coronavirus
and i remember thinking huh yup that's
really interesting
a crisis that will then force action
so you know what's interesting bill de
blasio mentioning he wants to buy up all
these buildings
yep he just came right out and said it
huh yeah and the mass evictions
they're putting homeless people in
luxury areas driving out wealthy people
yup nice house but that's also stripping
them of their income
then bernie sanders says he wants to tax
like 65
of all of the the the gains made from
billionaires
we're not talking about money made we're
talking about
if you had if like let me let me break
down for you what bernie sanders is
saying
i got this here a little little tim in a
jar right let's say this is worth five
bucks
yeah and then because of the pandemic a
cork and a little glass tube
and the things require you know required
become extremely rare
and now it's worth a hundred dollars yep
bernie's plan would require me to sell
this
and then give him 65 dollars so
the the idea so it's a tax on the wealth
gains
not cash so if i have no money
and this becomes valuable what do i have
to sell it i
guess so i guess so yeah because you
can't afford to
cover however much he wants from you i
wouldn't be surprised if following all
of this
we see a bunch of more social welfare
policies
enacted very heavily yeah and i see that
coming from the right or the left
i don't really think it matters i mean
if the country stays together
it will yeah but i
you know i i guess we could say we could
just say don't have an optimism bias
yeah you know um
optimism bias is basically when people
think it can't happen to me everything's
always great it's gonna be fine
and then it's not so would you say that
an optimism bias is what they had in
2016 when they were just
sure that their candidate would win
hillary
yep definitely yep so they and they have
it now too
yeah you know they they they picked
kamala and i saw this this progressive
guy i know say well i still think trump
was gonna lose
and i'm like man you just keep right on
thinking that bro
yeah yeah and then you're gonna lose yep
it's it's i want them to lose that's the
point
all the hillary people who said at home
we'll see if they learn their lesson
i kind of believe they didn't yeah
because i don't think they can yeah i
don't think so either they keep
advocating for censorship and then
getting silenced they're like wait wait
no like the
the young turks yeah you know what man
i've said it a million times but the
progressives should have been behind
trump
what makes you say that that's a little
crazy because
the democratic party the establishment
if they get back in the progressives are
done for trump
but that would require them to plan
ahead a little bit well so what happened
now
for all of you know basically what i see
happening is the progressives
didn't like trump but the establishment
started handing
handing out rocks and they gladly picked
the rocks up and throw them at trump as
well
it's actually like you know did you uh i
covered this on my main channel the
white house siege thing
yeah they're planning a 50-day siege of
the white house starting september 17th
and why so that the obama
administration's
you know second in command can take the
reins
yeah that's what they said they're like
you know obviously they want revolution
nothing less they say that
but are they they're gonna protest
donald trump so that biden can win
and then they they they pushed the
initial
uh article or was like add for occupy
wall street
their complaints were during the obama
administration why would they want to
empower the obama administration
because in in tandem with not being able
to look into the future
they also can't look into the past and
they can't assess the present to figure
out what the heck
is happening right now and why and what
it might have caused it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you